il nous faut un écrivain brillant qui
nous remettent sur le devant de la scène
je ne vends pas la maison d'édition
peut-être qu'un auteur mort qu'on
pourrait ressusciter il n'est pas mort
mais peut-être harris chaud oui je crois
qu'il est et moi
allons examiner son contrat est-ce que
je suis folle mois que j'ai bienvenus il
est dicté ses dires lanta perturbations
à leurs préoccupations il a tiré sur son
dernier assistant parce qu'il l'a
confondu avec un humour
je crois pas une seconde je suis lucie
sandridge des éditions stanbridge le
monde n'a aucun besoin de lire une mais
deux jours écrit au contraire est-ce
qu'il ya un manuscrit quelque part
[Musique]
les termes du contrat stipule que vous
faites la tournée sinon je ne peut
procéder à des retouches sur le livre
rien n'a tourné il me faudra toujours
une bouteille johnnie walker black label
ainsi qu'une boîte de cigares et des
cacahuètes celles qui sont salées
c'est très excitant
une tournée littéraire pourquoi je ne
vous dirai pas quelque chose
on se voit si le critique littéraire du
prime je n'aime pas les critiques
littéraires
tout ça c'est de la foutaise
à tous est logique que l'auteur qui a
fait connaître ses maisons d'édition
reçoit également le fossoyeur comprend
bien alors certes son sens adoré les
vieux machins les friteries il élimine
le communisme quoi le dit souvent on n'a
pas encore atteint la masse critique et
moi qui vais être dans un état critique
si ça continue
n'est pas de la propagande
c'est une expression de la vérité ce
sont vos moments parfois un homme doit
avoir l'audace de se montrer ambitieux
par exemple je suis sur le foie de fumée
et de piste en même temps et c'est quoi
la martha stewart du pauvre la cuisine
en moi le scotch en plus un jeu de rôles
jeux serait l'animateur qu'est ce qui
vous a inspiré pour ce nouveau roman je
ne vais pas grand chose d'autre à faire
de toute manière les téléspectateurs ont
changé de chaîne tu traînes sa renommée
dans la cour
il t'a rendu dingue c'est vrai
[Musique]
votre livre est officiellement à
best-seller à présent j'aurais dû me
mollet par le feu un peu plus tôt
l'irb l'étude en train de regarder toi
j'ai écris moi même mes livres au moins